on parle toujours de la magie des fêtes
mais honnêtement cette période de
l'année c'est beaucoup plus le son des
cartes de crédit qui retentit au pays
quand on se paye un noël à crédit con
mais ça coûte en réalité
selon un sondage de la cibc la famille
canadienne la dépense en moyenne 950 $
pour le temps des fêtes et 59% d'entre
eux vont utiliser leur carte de crédit
si on se fie aux banques il ya un peu
moins de la moitié des canadiens qui
seront pas capables de tout rembourser
d'ici la fin du mois donc beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui vont accumuler des
intérêts dont votre carte de crédit à un
taux de 18 pour ça si vous remboursez
vos dépenses des fêtes à coup de 100 $
par mois bien vous accumulez 83 $ en
intérêts au total et ça va vous prendre
aux oies pour tout rembourser bref vos
dépenses des fêtes vont être remboursés
juste à temps pour noël 2018
[Musique]
si vous croyez que c'est une bonne idée
de rembourser vos dépenses des fêtes en
ne payant que le minimum à chaque mois
eh bien ça va vous prendre 18 ans et
demi pour rembourser ce 950 dollars 950
dollars à coût de remboursement minimum
à chaque mois
ça coûte seulement l'intérêt accumulé
1781 dollars et ça si vous avez
uniquement vos dépenses des faillites
sur votre carte de crédit
or le sondage de la cibc révèle que 42 %
des canadiens se sentent obligés de
faire ces dépenses là même s'ils savent
qu'ils n'en ont pas les moyens
résultat les canadiennes en moyenne
solde impayé de 4000 85 dollars sur
leurs cartes de crédit
un montant comme ça si on ne rembourse
que le minimum à chaque mois ça prend
quarante trois ans à rembourser et on
accumule plus de onze mille dollars en
intérêts ok c'est toujours déprimant de
parler d'argent sur au temps des fêtes
mais il faut savoir faire attention et
éviter de se réveiller avec une gueule
de bois financière pour commencer la
nouvelle année sur ce joyeux serait
quand même
[Musique]